[Music]
like where I live
Rach rally we can finally be best
friends IRL okay zoo see you soon
Wow this is incredible hey Spencer I saw
you with the lockers you okay good fits
of a piper expensive some zombified zawa
I'm good he's fine something weird is
happening to the top students here kids
turn to lifeless zombies secret passages
we have to investigate hello maybe it's
on a person behind this week's be
following us I can feel it ghosts don't
exist
Griffin is up to something he has to be
behind this well I still think it was a
ghost
a fire ghost boo I need to bust into
that locker or we could do something
that won't lead to certain danger just
an idea
this robot engine is totally stable
unless it's overheated girls it's and
duty and Shane stickers guaranteed to
stop girls from loving that
so what we just give up no we're a team
we can do this we can do anything
things always work out you're something
good friends in on this we saw him going
to the Walker send a Spencer who's
behind this but what are you doing here
what are you doing here
I'm mopping that's what they all say
[Music]
[Applause]
chain keys
I'd be a real monster monsters aren't
real we'll see about that
[Music]
what sounds good
[Music]